all right well many of us are familiar
with workplace cliches like pay your
dues or wait your turn but identical
twin sisters Antoinette Clarke and
Tricia Clarke stone found success in the
corporate world playing by a new set of
rules the sisters share their tips for
success in the new book Double Down bet
on yourself and succeed on your terms
they reveal how anyone can shatter the
status quo build confidence and become
their best self Trisha Clarke stone is
CEO of WP narrative and award-winning
content innovation agency Antoinette
Clarke is a two-time Emmy winner and
senior vice president of branded
entertainment at CBS Corporation good
morning to both of you this book is
intended to help people become a boss
lady yes what is a boss lady so well
first we want to set the record straight
you don't have to be a CEO or an
entrepreneur to achieve boss-lady status
anyone can do it and it's basically it's
an essence it's a mode of being it's a
vibe and we think a boss lady really
embodies the notion of having an equal
element of IQ and EQ and it's all about
being a fearless optimist and don't ever
count her out because she will achieve
her goals how do you get to being that
person a few a few things we could go on
and on but essentially we think it's
having a level of confidence in yourself
compassion and they're all so cool
really leaning into your style and who
and what you are a it sounds like you
guys were lucky enough to have that with
your grandmother with your mother as an
examples what do you tell the people who
don't have that type of inspiration or
those women around them you too can be a
boss and own your destiny yeah and I
think a big thing is to really show that
you can be you can design your own level
of success and terms and we think you
don't have to follow a specific roadmap
or rule it's what you want it to be and
we're prime examples of that Trisha has
had a separate path I've had a separate
path but we've both risen up in the
ranks and found our own success in
different ways and it's about
surrounding yourself with the right
people we really focus on deliberate
cultivation of
the right people around you who raise
you up we say we're each other's gravity
and an elevation so you and you don't
have to have a twin to get that it could
be you and I would we become friends but
you also say all friends are not created
equal
yeah no that's the thing too it's and it
may sound harsh but it's not really that
harsh it's about we tend to kind of fall
into this place of passive accumulation
you know when you buy a blouse and you
get extra buttons and then two weeks
later you're like wow I've amassed a
bowl of buttons it's you have people in
your life that's really not serving you
so you really need to lean in and
identify who and what you want around
you you read about using your
superpowers to get ahead how did you tap
into these superpowers as 12 year old
selling guess what shirts we were very
crafty yeah so I think it was our cool
factor we knew what we liked oh we knew
what was cool and yes was big back in
the day we're now showing our age by
saying that hey I can style now it would
be worth a lot of money right now so you
were selling it you're in middle school
yeah so we were in high school at the
time and we found a shop on the upper
west side that was selling them at
discounted prices so Tricia and I would
save her for our birthday and Christmas
money and we said wow we think the girls
at our private school would love it
because we a dress down days and dress
down days you showed up in your best so
basically we took our cash bought 20
sweatshirts went to school the next day
when we a dress down we both rocked them
everyone was like where'd you get those
those look amazing we're like we have
one for you superpower it snowing and
doubling down on your white space we saw
a white space of just about in the booth
what is white space it's an it's an
opportunity and you really looking at
how you can solve a problem in a new way
or create something new and how did you
finish each other's sentences
sounds like you've been important for
each other oh my god and I think us
being twins have really shown us the
power of connection and the need to also
individuate and when you
look at how we there's been a while
factor since we were little and then
when we went to school we were no longer
together so they separated us in class
so we really had to figure sound upset
about that still right now I'm like they
separated but we're back together giving
them the side-eye
so basically we had to figure out how we
could create that wow factor as it's a
visual love the book love how you break
it up into two parts focus on yourself
and don't forget about your crew exactly
you have to double down on your crew
thank you both for being here and
DoubleDown goes on sale Tuesday